To learn languages,
we have to master the basics.
Is it true? No.
Breaking news:
It is not possible to master the basics, especially at the beginning.
We are going to continue making the same mistakes for a long time.
So we don't have to worry about this useless desire to master the basics.
What are the basics?
And I say this from my experience as a language learner.
Words, for example, what are basic words?
Many books that teach languages ​​start with, I
don't know, colors, numbers, but those things are very difficult.
There are words with more frequency, but in any case,
we will find these words with high frequency.
So, we'll learn those words more easily.
But certain words are still going to be difficult to remember,
right? The same thing with structures.
For me, for example, now I am speaking in Spanish, which I don't do much.
So I'm going to
Make basic mistakes.
But if I talk more, then I would make fewer basic mistakes, right?
So the basics are a very subjective concept.
And in any case, there is a natural order of acquisition of a language
according to what
Steven Krashen has done, for example, and this natural order of acquisition can depend
on the language we are learning and our language.
For example, an Italian who is learning Spanish,
well it will be easier, right?
Many things about grammar
and also the words are similar to words or structures in Italian.
So, there is a natural order that is different, but for someone who is
learning, for example, English, we all know that in English, the
third person present has an "S", for example, i go, you go, I GOES.
But this is very difficult.
It's a basic grammatical thing, but non-natives continue to make
this very simple mistake because we have to build new habits.
And this is done according to a natural order.
It is done throughout a long period of time, right?
So deliberately trying to learn, to master the basics
is useless and not helpful, because all the time we are trying
to learn, for example, conjugations, is time that I am not going
to use to listen more, read more, speak more, so that my brain
gets used to the new language.
And for that reason, on LingQ, for example, I always start with the mini stories
that are easy, with a lot of repetition, and in this way an idea of ​​the language is created.
Because we can finally focus on the basics AFTER we have a
feel for the language and we can finally, after a lot of experience with the language,
try to perfect, and not master, because we are going to
continue to make mistakes.
It is very important not to have a feeling of frustration.
If even after a long time we are making basic mistakes, because
this is the case with me,
I think it is the case with most people who learn languages.
So the most important thing is to stay active, keep listening, reading, enjoying
the language and little by little it will improve.
And if later you want to focus on certain aspects of vocabulary
or grammar, you can do that and it would be easier to assimilate those things,
Explanations, patterns, because ultimately, the foundation of the language is not like
building a house with bricks.
It's not like there's a foundation
And then we're going to build the second floor,
Third floor. No. It's like a bowl of jello.
Things come and go.
We learn and we forget.
And that is why at LingQ we do not measure student progress
because this is difficult.
Sometimes we have the impression of making progress and then we don't.
But what we can measure
And the most important thing is the level of activity of each one.
And if the student continues to be active, listening, reading, over time,
using the language, with a positive attitude, it is certain that he will progress.
So my advice, as a person who has learned
many languages ​​at different levels, is that we cannot master the basic things.
You have to continue studying, read interesting things. And little by little
We are going to get used to the new language, without bothering ourselves with this
desire to master the basics.
See you later.